this is the terrible impact of covid
on one family the coffins of a mother
next to her two sons in november
they shared a funeral after losing their
lives to the virus
within five days of each other
gladys lewis who was 74 and her sons
darren and dean in their early forties
a part of the 100 000 people who've died
from the disease the figures are
frightening
for their family it's really scary it's
really
terrified i got this fear of losing as
well i can
worry like if my father i'll catch you
again or if one of my kids or
you know a close member of the family
i'm just worried all the time i'm gonna
lose somebody else
it is devastating and i wouldn't like
any family
goes through what we do the former
mining communities of the ronda valley
in south wales
have the highest death rate from the
virus in the uk
a bunch of doctors down 40 percent of
hospital beds are
taken by covered patients i don't think
in my
in my worst nightmare i ever thought
we'd get to these sorts of numbers
um in you know purely in our health
board we've had over 1
200 deaths which is
nothing i ever considered here
the fast spreading variant is
responsible
for around 30 percent of cases
in this community i'm told that
everybody knows someone affected by
covid and the numbers keep going up
not just here but nationally only
a few months ago there were 50 000
deaths linked to the virus in the uk
now that figure has doubled
it means that the number of funerals
have been relentless
what what has been unprecedented is is
the constant
flow of funerals that we've had coming
coming into the into the business the
firm
and it doesn't seem any let up with that
and it hasn't been really since last
spring
like so many this doctor has been
redeployed
to care for covered patients it's a very
precarious position
the one that i think we are just getting
on top of and hopefully getting out of
now and hopefully this will be the last
wave and peak that we see
with the vaccines coming on board but i
think we're all facing the next few
weeks and months with
a cautious optimism these nhs workers
have given their all
to save lives but that hasn't prevented
a hundred thousand deaths in this
pandemic
and a fear of how many more are to come
lisa dowd sky news south wales